One of the great things that I,
that I love about what I do is we get to
take on some of the biggest challenges
in global health and global development.
And one of those challenges is water,
sanitation and hygiene.
Um,
everybody needs clean water and you
know,
uh,
to quote the book,
everybody poops.
And,
uh,
dealing with this in a clean and
sanitary way is really important for
quality of life and it's also really
important for health and getting rid of
certain diseases.
One of the biggest challenges over the
last couple of years,
uh,
a really fun technological challenges
has been the reinvent the toilet
project.
Uh,
the basic theme of this was looking at
are there new solutions,
21st century solutions to sanitation,
echoing what we saw in a telephone and
communication systems where a lot of
countries completely skipped over
building a,
a big network of landlines and
traditional phones and went straight to
cell phones.
Uh,
the question was,
could we come up with the equivalent
technology that would jump over building
out sewer networks in giant water,
expensive water treatment plants,
and jump immediately to non-network
sanitation.
And it turns out that new approaches are
possible using mechanical engineering
and chemical engineering approaches.
Uh,
there's actually a lot of free energy in
the waste that can be used to process
itself if,
uh,
the machine to do it is designed
correctly and you can actually do this
in a fairly cost effective way.
So the reinvent the toilet challenge was
kicked off,
uh,
about five years ago,
in order to,
uh,
get universities,
different companies,
design firms and so on to actually think
about this and put a 21st century
innovation applied to the problem of a
human sanitation.
And it's been remarkably,
uh,
cool and successful so far to see the
different approaches that have come up.
There was one team of a lot of hurts
fellows that,
uh,
started,
working on figuring out new ways to do
use pyrolysis and other approaches for
using electrolysis for drying.
And combusting one group is running a
steam engine off of,
uh,
human waste as the input stream and
we're a community would use to have,
uh,
10 tons of waste the day.
Now all of a sudden a,
it runs a,
a steam engine that generates 150
kilowatts of electricity and puts out
10,000 to 20,000 liters a day of potable
water.
So this is just really exciting to see
what innovation can do,
what new technologies can do,
and actually,
uh,
taking on some of these really big
challenges in saying what would be a
really definitive technological solution
to this that actually solves the problem
in a way that we would never have
imagined trying 25 or 30 years ago.